donald trump signe son retour en
campagne ignorant les mises en garde sur
le coronavirus le président américain
renault hier soir avec les
rassemblements dont ils raffolent mais
sans la foule attendue un meeting
d'envergure avec pour objectif donner un
coup de fouet à une campagne de
réélection
mal engagés qui divise les américains
grégoire tout s'est réalisé moins de
tests pour ralentir le nombre de cas
avérés
voilà la stratégie prônée par le
président américain ce samedi lors de
son meeting comme souvent difficile
d'affirmer s'il s'agit d'un calcul
teintée d'ironie ou de propos sérieux de
la part du milliardaire donald trump qui
a signé un retour attendu par ses
partisans
si l'affluence n'était pas à la hauteur
des attentes de son équipe de campagne
il était tout de même plusieurs milliers
à venir afficher leur soutien dans la
ville de tall ça dans l'oklahoma
nous commençons notre temps paille je
voulais juste tous vous remercier vous
êtes des guerriers lorsque vous faites
autant de tests vous allez trouver plus
de gens affectés
vous allez trouver plus de cas j'ai donc
dit à mes collaborateurs
s'il vous plaît ralentissent et les
tests ils font des tests et encore des
tests nous avons eu des tests où les
gens ne savaient pas ce qui se passait
nous avons fait des tests nous en avons
un autre ici le jeune garçon qui a 10
ans qui a le nez qui coule
il s'en remettra une quinzaine de
minutes plus tard c'est un car c'est un
cas un tel rassemblement est toujours
redoutée en raison des risques accrus de
propagation du coronavirus dernier
sanders s'est indigné de l'organisation
de cet événement selon le sénateur du
vermont
trump est prêt à propager le coït 19
juste pour entendre quelques
acclamations
six personnes parmi les organisateurs
ont d'ailleurs été testée positive avant
le meeting est immédiatement placé en
quarantaine à sur l'équipe de campagne
si le pays déplore près de 120 mille
décès liés à la maladie le président
américain a défendu coûte que coûte son
bilan à propos de cette crise le coc
vite 19
ce nom s'éloigne de plus en plus de la
chine alors qu'on l'appelait le virus
chinois
[Applaudissements]
et malgré le fait que nous moi avons
fait un travail phénoménal avec ce virus
j'ai fermé les états unis à une
population très fortement affecté
notamment à tous les gens venant de
chine à la fin janvier
c'est à dire des mois plus tôt que ce
que d'autres personnes aurait fait s'il
l'avait fait j'ai sauvé des centaines de
milliers de vies on n'en parle même pas
[Musique]
entre des sondages en berne la sortie
imminente du livre à charge contre lui
signé par son ex conseiller à la
sécurité john bolton ou encore les
nombreuses manifestations hostiles à sa
politique
le président des états unis traversent
une période difficile
il lui reste cinq mois pour renverser la
vapeur et briguer un second mandat